[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español la llegada al poder de los
talibanes en afganistán en agosto pasado
encendió los alertas entre los
organismos y agencias que se ocupan del
patrimonio cultural de la humanidad la
destrucción de los budas gigantes de
bamiyán centro de afganistán en 2001 por
los talibanes que gobernaban entonces
ese país abrió una herida que sigue
hasta ahora y que ha causado alerta
entre los que protegen la cultura y que
lleva a preguntarse si esta situación de
tragedia podría repetirse ahora para
hablar de esta situación así como de la
restitución de piezas culturales que
también se produce en el mundo saludamos
a ernesto ottone es un director general
de cultura de la unesco la organización
de las naciones unidas para la educación
la ciencia y la cultura ernesto tono
bienvenido a esta escala en parís muchas
gracias por la invitación un gusto para
nuevamente gracias por abrirnos un
espacio en su agenda que es bastante
cargada por ciento los talibanes son
responsables de un crimen que en su
momento es califico contra la cultura
por el antiguo director general de la
unesco en 2001 le buscábamos esta
situación ahora ellos se han
comprometido a respeto el patrimonio
donde estamos en este terreno hoy en día
es grande esto puede haber me está en
una situación un poco distinta a 2001 es
decir si bien son las mismas autoridades
que vuelven al gobierno
lo que ha cambiado son tres cosas lo
primero es que durante todos estos años
democráticos de afganistán el gobierno
saliente ratificó todas las convenciones
que afganistán hasta ese entonces no
había ratificado es decir el tráfico
ilícito en zonas de conflicto cuando la
protección y la salvaguarda del
patrimonio el patrimonio inmaterial por
lo tanto hoy día hay ciertas
responsabilidades internacionales del
país como afganistán en donde la mirada
internacional está puesta en el respeto
de esos acuerdos internacionales lo
segundo es que
efectivamente han habido indicaciones y
por lo menos es la información que
tenemos hasta ahora con nuestro equipo
que trabajan en el terreno que las
destrucciones que se dieron durante tres
años
el 2000
2009 y 2002 no se han producido en la
escala que se produjeron en ese entonces
pero estamos
constantemente trabajando y verificando
nuestro peligro mayor en este momento es
los sitios arqueológicos es decir el
control de los sitio arqueológico
a este respecto precisamente se estima
que hay 1000 piezas que se perdieron que
fueron robadas que fueron saqueadas
precisamente en este sitio de bamiyán
después de la toma del poder estos
últimos meses cuál es la situación de
las cifra exacta no las tenemos o cifras
que se lanzaron nosotros tuvimos un
seminario en noviembre el año pasado
donde vino el director del museo
de de
emoción nacional del museo nacional
perdón y no podía certificar nos cifra
lo que hubo es en los primeros días
mucho gusto el material técnico es decir
hay que saber que el trabajo que venimos
haciendo hace más de 18 años como unesco
ha sido con soporte y apoyo financiero
de muchos países alemania italia japón y
korea principalmente entonces lo que
desaparecieron con todo lo equipo wow
ahora también tenemos información de
algunas datos de cifras menores de sitio
de robo en los dos museos principales
pero lo más importante es que al no
estar inventariados los sitio
arqueológico y allí hay un control muy
difícil de hacer seguimiento porque una
pieza que está registrado uno tiene
interpol tiene servicio nacional de
internacional de aduanas que puede hacer
seguimiento y la unesco trabaja con icom
y con otra agencia especializada en caso
del sitio arqueológico donde se va
descubriendo y donde se va lo
especialista van descubriendo nuevas
cosas que no están registradas no hay
control lo que hemos hecho en estos
cuatro meses último es un llamado muy
fuerte
para que el mercado no adquiera pieza
proveniente afganistán sin que haya el
resguardo necesario del origen es decir
si hay pieza en el pasado que fueron
sacados del país tenemos registro hoy en
día estamos en un llamado para que no se
adquieran piezas provenientes de
afganistán en el mercado ni formal y por
supuesto menos informal que es ilegal
entonces hay pasos que se han dado
adelante está la protección
internacional que usted evocaba está
también la situación de que finalmente
el museo nacional afgano de kabul ha
reabierto segundo entiendo se estimen
280 mil piezas que hay allí adentro
parece ser que le están protegiendo más
o menos pero para ustedes el personal de
la unesco tuvo que salir del país en un
primer momento se desplazó a pakistán no
es muy difícil precisamente vigilar
supervisar esa situación sabiendo la
extensión de un país que para que
ustedes lo sepan es el equivalente de
alemania e italia juntos este es una
superficie enorme con más de 5000 sitios
arqueológicos más de 5 mil años de
historia ha de ser muy muy complicado
poder supervisar toda esta riqueza
cultural sí y hay que saber que además
la pandemia es esa la pandemia en el
mundo ha afectado todo el resguardo del
patrimonio mundial de la humanidad y por
lo tanto los dos efectos es decir el
cambio político que se produce en el
territorio afgano más la pandemia que ya
tenía muy maltratar las instituciones
públicas de resguardo del patrimonio
vienen a afectar sobre todo el
seguimiento y el control lo bueno es que
en los últimos tres meses nuestro equipo
han vuelto sobre este equipo
internacionales los aspectos el gran
problema que tenemos es el acceso a todo
le doy un ejemplo uno de los proyectos
que estábamos trabajando con el eve que
una agencia internacional también que
trabaja con unesco era la recuperación
de lo que se llama alminares the jam
problemas que no tengo acceso no es
talibanes que he cortado la ruta
entonces nuestro especialista tuvimos
que hacer todo con drones con monitores
que no es lo mismo que ir al lugar
entonces tenemos la los registros los
investigadores pudieron hacer informes
es un informe en base a imágenes y no a
una realidad de ver eso lo único que
puedo podemos acelerar hoy en día es que
esos espacios están resguardados es
decir hay seguridad puesta por los
talibanes para que no ingrese personas
no autorizadas pero lo que esté pasando
ahí es muy poca la información que
tenemos ahora es evidente que es una
prioridad solver en guardar precisamente
este patrimonio cultural al mismo tiempo
dadas las necesidades la urgencia
humanitaria
me imagino que esta situación corre el
riesgo de quedar relegada a un segundo
término más allá por ejemplo de este
bloqueo que ustedes menciona que hacen
los talibán cual sería hoy el principal
obstáculo que la unesco encuentra para
tratar de sobre guardar precisamente ese
rico patrimonio cultural por ejemplo
entiendo que había un centro cultural si
ustedes iban a abrir y que no se quedó
en ascuas mientras llegaron ellos que
ese centro cultural que un centro
información que lo que venía es a
entregar un espacio a la comunidad
afgana internacional
la rica historia que usted mencionó
estamos dando a cinco mil años de
civilización
pero también era el museo donde se iban
a rescatar restaurar parte de las piezas
de lo que era lo que fue lo que llevó de
los budas que se destruyeron 2001 el
museo o sea el museo el centro cultural
se iba a inaugurar dos semanas después
que igual cambio wind
para nosotros fue un golpe de agua fría
muy grande digamos inaugurado en octubre
financiado con fondos coreanos por lo
tanto hay un interés también
internacional de asegurar que la
inversión que se hizo el espacio físico
está listo pero está vacío hoy en día lo
que se ha tratado de hacer es asegurar
que las piezas que van a estar en ese
espacio estén resguardadas y eso nuestro
especialista local es importante no los
internacionales hoy en día nos tienen
acelerado que están resguardados y eso
nos dará una cierta tranquilidad pero
efectivamente tanto el país que invirtió
como la unesco no quiere que ese espacio
sea usado con otros fines que no son
para los cuales fue creado es decir no
se puede transformar en un espacio de
culto no se puede transformar estamos
hablando si no me equivoco de 8.000
metros cuadrados estamos hablando de un
edificio con su cuento secuencia para
venta y que tiene cinco museos en todo
el país esto pone hablamos de alistar
pero evidentemente la situación se puede
toda proporción guardada claro está
planteada a nivel internacional los
problemas que siempre existen en
términos de empresa del patrimonio
cultural hay cosas positivas al mismo
tiempo recientemente a finales del año
pasado el gobierno francés anunció que
devolvía finalmente piezas que fueron
llevadas por las tropas francesas en el
siglo 19 del vena del bening no hay el
propósito de devolver otras piezas a
otros países de áfrica esto supone para
ustedes un cambio de orientación una
tendencia que puede mejorarse que puede
llevar a una restitución de piezas de
aquellos lugares donde realmente hubo
saqueo notablemente en el siglo 19 bueno
está una discusión muy antigua en la
unesco ya el 78 el ex director general
en book
planteó la necesidad un discurso que
hasta el día de hoy recordamos el tema
la restitución de obra
se crearon instrumentos normativos
nosotros tenemos en la convención del
año 70 que sobre tráfico ilícito pero
que creó un comité especial que vela
cuando no hay acuerdos bilaterales de
hacer mediación entre los países para
tema de restitución en el caso de los 26
objetos que mencionamos
que entre ellas está en verano el resto
serán restituidos y que van a seguir con
costa marfil y otros países es un
ejemplo a mí me tocó participar con
electores general hace menos de dos
meses en washington en el smithsonian
donde eeuu entregó 17 mil piezas de
vuelta a irak de los cuales el más
importante era game que el a las
tabletas andamos que el plan sea
extraordinario me tocó participar de
todo ese proceso y efectivamente
buena de la restitución a guatemala de
una estela hace muy poco de un privado
de una cosa nueva es decir un privado
donde hay un reclamo de un país frente a
un objeto que fue de robado porque ahí
están la información y lo más complejo
en esto es que hay que separar dos
discusiones uno es la devolución de
objetos de arte que están protegidos por
la convención de 70 es decir cuando un
país ratifica estamos dando a 191 países
sueldos 193 que han ratificado una vez
que ratifican a partir de ahí todo
objeto que se pueda comprobar que fue
sacado de un país tiene que ser devuelto
el problema que tenemos que esta
discusión de la época colonial o de la
época también de américa latina es que
hoy en día está muy activo en este tema
méxico guatemala perú entre otros es
quien no lo cubre ningún instrumento
normativo hoy en día son acuerdos
bilaterales y el gran problema son 21
son las legislaciones nacionales que son
muy divergentes entre un país o algunos
no permiten que un patrimonio que está
incluido en el acervo cultural de ese
país pueda ser devuelto porque sería
como sacar una parte del país o sea ya
lo incorporan como parte de su
patrimonio y los otros países dicen que
cualquier objeto que haya salido a ese
país por ejemplo méxico precolombino
le pertenece tiene que ser devuelto
automáticamente entonces tenemos choques
de legislaciones hoy en día lo que
estamos haciendo es buscar la forma de
mediar entre los países que tienen
legislaciones
divergentes ese trabajo va a ser muy
largo hay que ser muy honesto hay un
cambio porque se produjo un cambio en la
sociedad hoy en día hay parte de la
sociedad civil que reconoce
que ese objeto no es solamente el valor
o económico es el valor identitario y
eso lo que estamos peleando pues
lamentablemente se nos va el tiempo no
me queda sino agradecerle a ernesto
ottone subdirector general de cultura de
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la educación la ciencia y la
cultura unesco su presencia en nuestros
estudios gracias por habernos acompañado
en esta escala en parís ernestro donde a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita la
próxima semana aquí en otra escala en
parís
[Música]